hello, how are you, andrés gonzález,
with the informative brain for today, Monday
, March 8, today marks the second
week of hybrid learning for
some cis students and that day
many families who made this
educational option, so the school district
took the initiative  to start with this
learning model after a
survey of parents,
meanwhile those who do not
feel safe can continue to opt
for full-time distance learning,
however this model is
only available for students in pre-
kindergarten through third grade  but on March 22,
grades 6, 9, and 12 will be added
on April 6, grades 7, 8,
10, and 11 will return, also on the same day
, elementary school students will return to
face-to-face classes 5 days a
week for a year now  practically
all the events began to close in
the city but little by little this is
changing this week of blues and yes and
lewis and they are  back in the organized
harina de vigo is in mandalay bay
while mansión west in the thomas &
mack center of layún alvin de pactual
returns within the flour scam
however for the moment
none of these games will be allowed to the public
and now  we turn to the weather forecast
we will have some gray in the valley
during the day reaching 70 degrees
by the afternoon the temperatures
will drop again for the rest of the week
staying at 50 degrees
have an excellent day I am andrés
gonzález and that was your  brief
informative genius nao in Spanish
[Music]